[Music]
good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is National Master Ralph tan and
welcome to beginner breakdown today
we're going to take a dive into the
concepts of pins how we can create pins
and utilize pins to the maximum
Advantage so let's take a look at this
position between BAU versus you in
1983 so first things first what is a pin
so a pin is a tactic where we can use a
piece to attack another piece an
opposing piece and that piece can't move
at all otherwise the piece behind it
will be in danger and the TP and
typically the piece that's behind it is
either higher of value or unprotected so
let's evaluate this position here so it
is black to move so black has 1 2 3 4
Five Pawns white has 1 2 3 4 Five Pawns
as well so both sides are equivalent
Pawn wise both sides respectively have
their queen and the Rook pair so looks
like both sides are equivalent in
material and I would say both sides for
their kings are relatively safe so let's
see if we have a pen in this position so
what we can notice here is that our Rook
on
A2 is pinning this Rook on C2 towards
the queen so this Rook on C2 can't move
at all otherwise the queen would be in
danger so for example let's just make a
random move if the Rook ever moves away
then the queen would be captured by The
Rook so since we have this pin we want
to try to utilize it
and make the most of it so whenever we
have a pin we want to bring more
pressure into the pin piece so The Rook
is the PIN piece and our attackers are
The Rook on A2 and our Queen on E5 so we
have two attackers and for white they
have two Defenders on the C2 Rook so the
Defenders will win so if Rook captures
Queen captures Queen Rook rook and it's
equivalent so how could we possibly put
more pressure onto the CT Rook so a lot
of us are saying in chat that Rook to C3
is our move and with Rook to
C3 this Rook is now putting more
pressure onto this Rook on C2 so we have
one two three attackers in total while
white has two Defenders now after this
move Rook to to C3 it looks like white
has a couple options here they could
either take this Rook on C3 or take the
Rook on A2 now if they take the Rook on
C3 now this Rook on A2 is open to
capturing this queen on
E2 and we would be up
material however if white captures The
Rook on A2 that means this Rook on C1 is
undefended so we had another pin
alongside the C file so after Rook takes
A2 Rook takes C1 with a check if the
king moves away to H2 then we could
deliver mate by either Queen to H1
Checkmate or Rook to H1 Checkmate and
there's no other good moves just white
blocks with the queen then we could
capture the queen and after King takes
we can deliver to move Queen to B1
forking the king and Rook winning even
even more material so King G2 Queen
takes
A2 so let's do some practice how about
this position with Donner versus hubner
in
1968 and it is black to move so let's
evaluate the position black has one two
three four pawns white has 1 two 3 four
five six pawns so white is up Pawn wise
up by two pawns and both sides have a
queen and Rook okay and both sides I
would say are relatively safe with their
kings and what we can notice here in
this position is that we have already a
pin here along the B6 to G1 diagonal so
the queen is pinning the the queen on C5
to the King on G1 so this queen on G5
can't move anywhere otherwise the queen
on B6 will be attacking the King on
B1 so what could we do to fully utilize
and maximize our advantage alongside
this pin that we have how could we put
more pressure onto the queen on
C5 perfect a lot of us are saying the
move Rook to C8 and now with the move
Rook to C8 it is attacking the queen on
C5 so originally before Rook C8 the
queens were looking at each other so we
have one attacker on the queen on C5
while white has one Defender so white
would live after this exchange happens
but after Rook to C8 we are now
threatening to attack the queen so if a
move like Pawn to B4 then we can just
simply capture the queen with our rook
and we would win material here but now
the question is what happens after the
queen takes Our Queen on
B6 if we naively capture the queen back
looks like our Rook on C8 is undefended
so they can take their Rook on C1 and
capture our rook and they would be a up
material so in this case what we want to
do is create a little intermediate move
an in between move so instead of making
the obvious move of capturing Our Queen
back we want to play Rook takes see1
with a check so since white is in check
they have to react to it so with this
check in mind the white king would have
to go to F2 and then and now we can
capture the queen on B6 and we are up a
whole Rock Perfect all right let's take
a look at this example we have shumu
versus wiow in
1875 and it is white to move here so
first things first let always always
evaluate the position so white has 1 2 3
4 Five Pawns black has 1 2 three so
looks like we are up two pawns that's
white perfect both sides have their Rook
Pairs and both sides have a queen but it
looks like in compensation for our two
pawns black has a bishop a bishop for it
and what we can also notice is that we
have a pin set in place so this queen on
A4 is pinning this queen on C6 towards
the King on E8 so this queen cannot move
to any other Square let's say C5
otherwise the King on E8 would be in
danger and in addition Our Queen on A4
is unprotected so if we don't react
properly then I believe they can capture
outward Queen on A4 for
free so what could we possibly do here
in this position
so since we have this pin along A4 to E8
we want to put more pressure onto this
queen on C6 and the move is Rook to
C1 and as we play Rook to C1 now we're
bringing this Rook to attack the queen
so we have two attackers in total The
Rook on C1 and the Queen on A4 and black
only has one Defender The Rook on
C8 but after Rook to C1 it looks like
black could capture Our Queen on A4 but
fortunately for us we can take our Rook
on C1 and capture The Rook on C8
delivering Checkmate so we have our
classic ladder mate with both the Rooks
on B7 and C8 controlling both
ranks excellent all right how about this
one here so we have rosenal versus wal
in 1977 and it is white to move so it's
always good to evaluate the position
first so white has one two pawns black
has one two three pawns so black is up
one Pawn both sides respectively have
the rook and dark Square Bishops here so
in this position we notice we can notice
that we have a pin set in place with our
Bishop pinning this bishop on E5 towards
the King on h8 so this bishop can't move
to any other squares like D6 otherwise
the king would be end dangered but as we
have this pin we can't necessarily
capture this bishop otherwise black will
simply capture back with their rook and
they'll be perfectly fine so what could
we do to maybe utilize and take
advantage of this pin
here perfect we have the move Rook to B8
now with Rook to B8 we are bringing
another pin into this position so if
block captures our Bishop on D4 then
what we can do is capture this Rook on
E8 with a check and now once the king
moves away then we can take our Pawn on
C3 and capture the bishop Bishop on
D4 now what happens if the Rook on E8
captures our Rook on B8 since it's
completely undefended well if the Rook
captures our Rook on B8 then we can take
our Bishop on D4 and capture the bishop
on E5 because it is no longer protected
by The Rook we have deflected The Rook
away so when Bishop takes E5 it not only
attacks the king it also attacks attacks
The Rook so after the king moves to B8
then uh G8 then we can take our Bishop
and capture The Rook on B8 and we would
simply win material
excellent all right how about this
position we have perk versus staltz in
1931 there black to move so this
position has a little bit of a Twist
it's a more than a one move combination
here so it's always good to evaluate the
position so black has 1 2 3 4 5 six
pawns white has 1 2 3 four Five Pawns so
black is up a
pawn both sides have a rook both sides
have a queen and in compensation here
white has two minor pieces for a our
Rook so they are up the
material so what we can notice here is
that we have our Rook on E8 pinning this
Pawn on E3 and it's a pin because this
Pawn cannot capture as it usually would
otherwise the King on E1 would be in
danger and in addition we do also have
another tactic up Our Sleeve which is
either to move Queen to A1 check or
queen to C1 check and it would be a
skewer because if the king moves away
then our Rook on H1 would be captured
but unfortunately here after Queen to uh
C1 there's the move Knight to D1 to
interfere the check and after Queen to
A1 there is also the move Knight to B1
or Knight to D1 to stop the
check so how do we fully utilize this
pen and to our fullest Advantage how do
we put pressure onto this Pawn on
E3 so excellent I see a lot of us in
chat saying Pawn to D4 Pawn to D4 is a
perfect move because this Pawn on E3
can't capture this Pawn on
D4 and this Knight If It Moves away then
this queen on D3 is completely
unprotected so our Queen on A3 will
capture the queen on D three for free so
we also have another pin set in place
but now the big question is what happens
if white just simply captures the pawn
on D4 with our
Queen now we can set in place what we
had earlier before and that would be the
move Queen to A1 delivering a skewer
along the first rank so if the king
moves away let's say to E2 or D2 either
either one doesn't matter then we can
take our Queen on A1 all the way to the
other side of the board and capture The
Rook on
H1 now if white tries to block the check
with the Knight on D1 then we could
actually capture this queen on D4 and
unfortunately for white this Pawn on E3
can't take back on D4 because a a rook
on E8 hinting the pawn on E3 and last
but not least if white tries to
interpose the check with a move like
Queen D1 then that leaves this Knight on
C3 completely undefended so we can
capture the Knight and we would be up
the exchange Rook for
Bishop excellent all right how about we
try this position we have casparo versus
brown in
1979 and it is a white to move so let's
evaluate the position white has 1 2 3
four Five Pawns black has one two three
four five pawns as well so both sides
are equivalent Pawn wise both sides have
a queen both sides have a rook and both
sides also have their light Square
Bishops so in this position we actually
don't have a pin in this position so
what we need to do is create a pen so
how would we want to create a pen well
we want to take a look at where our
pieces are placed
and how we can use that to our advantage
so specifically this Rook on A7 and a
typical pattern that is good principle
for Rooks is that they love open files
because they can move freely up and down
and in addition they love the seventh
rank because that's where all the pawns
originate and if given the chance white
can take the rook and capture the pawns
and with this in mind maybe we could
line up some pieces together of black
and then utilize that
pink so perfect I see a lot of us in
chat saying to move Bishop to H7 with a
check so it looks like we are
voluntarily giving our Bishop away but
with this bishop on H7 if the black king
takes our
Bishop bam we have a pin along the
seventh rank so that means this Pawn on
F7 can't move at all so it can't push
forward or it can no longer really
defend this bishop on E6 and with that
in mind we can take Albert Queen on E5
and capture the bishop on E6 and the
pawn can't capture the queen because of
this Rook on A7 and now with this in
mind black is actually suffering here so
let's say if black tries to continue
with Pawn takes B2 with a threat of
promoting next move what we can simply
do is just capture the pawn on F7 with
the queen and after the king runs away
to corner and h8 then we can deliver
checkmate with either Queen to G D7 or
queen to
H7 excellent so creating and utilizing
pins in this situation and in addition
if the black king does ignore the bishop
on H7 and let's say moves along to f8
then unfortunately that ends the game on
the spot as the queen on D on E5 can
slide over to the corner on ha and
deliver Checkmate as it guards the
eighth rank Pawn guards E7 and the queen
also guards the G7
Square
perfect how about this position so we
have Hansen versus mhler in
1962 and it is black to move here so
let's evaluate the position black has 1
two 3 four Five Pawns okay white has 1 2
3 four Five Pawns as well so both sides
are equivalent Pawn wise both sides have
a rook but the imbalance here is that
white has a rook for our Bishop so they
are up the exchange here so in this
position we don't really have a pin set
in place so we're going to need to
create a pin and then start utilizing it
for our advantage
here so we can also notice that we have
a lot of pressure onto this G2 Pawn we
have the Rook on G8 attacking it pawn
attacking it and in addition this bishop
attacking the pawn as well so that's
three attackers in total while white
only has one and two Defenders on the
pawn so The Rook on D2 and the King on
H1 so maybe the move includ cludes or
hints at taking this Pawn on G2 but the
question is what do we do
after we capture on D2 so let's just
take a look with Pawn takes as it's very
pleasing to the eye because it's one
square away from promotion but after
King to G1 I believe we are hitting a
bit of a stump here for black because
there's nothing really we can do
furthermore because our Bishop is on a
light square and the king is on a dark
square and we can't necessarily bring
our Rook to the first rank in a properly
fashioned so it seems to be that Rook
takes G2 is in the
move so Rook takes G2 if the Rook
captures back on G2 we somewhat have a
pin here our Bishop is lining up towards
the Rook on G2 and the King on H1 but
it's not a true pin yet because there is
this Pawn on F3 so we're going to have
to get rid of the pawn if we just
capture The Rook we're kind of just
stuck here as black so the move here is
just simply ignoring the rook and just
pushing the pawn up and with pushing the
pawn to F2 our Bishop on e4 is pinning
The Rook on G2 to the King on
H1 so the Rook can't move at all so it
can't capture the pawn on F2 otherwise
the bishop would be attacking the king
and white really has nothing to stop our
Pawn from promoting so promotion is
inevitable here so let's just say for
example if white just continues with
capturing on B5 then we can just promote
to a queen and after the king moves away
then we can deliver checkmate with Queen
takes G2 supported by the bishop Bishop
on
e4 so that's what happens if the Rook
takes but let's just say h white just
tries to ignore the threat on G2 and
just simply moves back to the first r
with Rook to
D1 so we still want to utilize this
advantage of our Bishop being lined up
towards the King on H1 so what we can do
here is pretty much follow the same idea
of just pushing this Pawn to F2 and
white is in big trouble because there is
a
discovery uh check here so let's say for
example if Rook to F1 to kind of stop
the pawn from promoting we just have
Rook to G1 check so it is a double check
and a discovery check so after the king
moves away we capture The Rook and Ma is
right around the corner so whatever
white does let's say they capture on B5
then we just play Rook to H1 check
me perfect we are on a
roll all right how about we try this
position we have hoft versus Weber in
1973 and it is white to move here so
first things first we should always
evaluate the position so white has one
two three pawns black also has one two
three pawns as well both sides have a
queen both sides have a rook and both
sides also in addition have the bishop
here so it is white to move here
and through evaluation here we don't
really have a pin set in place so looks
like we're going to have to create a pin
and then utilize it to our maximum
Advantage here
but we can also notice if we put
ourselves in black shoes then we can see
that black has a couple pins on us our
Bishop on G1 can't move otherwise the
queen would be attacking the King on H1
and our Pawn on H2 can't really
capture uh anything that's on G3 because
the king would be in danger and also in
addition there is this nice little idea
where if white is a bit careless then
there's this move Rook takes H2 check
and after the king takes the queen can
slide all over to H H5 and after the
king moves then black can just pick up
the rook and simply be winning more
material so we're going to have to react
in a proper manner
here so why to move and in addition we
can notice that a lot of our pieces are
kind of aim
towards the opposing King so our Queen
Bishop Rook they're they're in action
they're ready to attack the
king so in chat we have the move Rook to
G8 lovely first move so we are making an
active move we are delivering a check
and black has to react to a check so
whenever a king is in check they can
either block the check capture the piece
that's checking the king or move away so
black I can't really capture G8
if Black Blocks with Bishop to C8 then
we have a pin here but after this we can
just end the game here and there with
Queen to B6 Checkmate as a bishop covers
A8 and the queen attacks the king and
takes away its remaining safe
squares so it looks like the King has to
move away so King to A7 is to move here
for
black so what could we do here after
this
position so what we can notice is
that we have a light Square Bishop
that's in action and we want to kind of
lurt a king into a light square
and take advantage of that so the move
here that we want to try to look for is
this sly little move Rook to A8 so we
are giving up our Rook but in
compensation we will be winning the game
so if the bishop captures The Rook on A8
we have this move Queen to C7 with a
check and Black's only move is to block
with the bishop and after the bishop
blocks then we can take our Queen on C7
and cap capure the bishop on B7
delivering mate as it's supported by our
Bishop on
D5 now what happens if the black king
takes on A8 well after the black king
takes the Rook we have our theme for
today the pin so this bishop can't move
to a square like C8 otherwise this
bishop on D5 will be attacking theing
King on A8 but now how could we apply
pressure and attack and utilize this pin
that we have going alongside D5 to the
A8
diagonal so the move here is Queen takes
A6 with a check and after Queen takes A6
with a check that black Bishop cannot
take the queen on A6 because this bishop
on D4 would be attacking the King on A8
and once the king simply slides on over
then we can end the game here and there
by capturing the bishop on B7 with our
Queen and it is Checkmate as it's
supported by our Bishop on
D5 all right how about we take a look at
this position so we have two unknown
players in
1949 and it is black to move move here
so always a good thing to evaluate the
position black has 1 2 3 4 Five Pawns
white has one two three four five six
seven pawns so white is up Pawn Wise by
two and both sides have a queen and both
sides have a
rook so we can also notice that in this
position white is dominating to seventh
rank they have a battery so a battery is
when two or more pieces are working
together to control a file rank or
diagonal and in this case the queen or
Rook the queen and Rook are just
dominating the seventh Rank and it is
attacking Our Queen on D7 so it looks
like we are in a little bit of trouble
here and we don't have a pin here is
black so we're going to need to create
one and then utilize it to add our
advantage
here so we can also notice that in this
position the white King on
G1 is in a little bit of trouble because
doesn't really have too much air to
breathe there's Pawns in its way and
it's only safe squares are H1 and F1 so
black so white has a back ring problem
so maybe we could try to bring one of
our pieces either the queen or The Rook
to the last rank to deliver the idea of
Checkmate
so we
have so yeah so there is that idea that
this Rook on C7 is pinned because if the
Rook moves away then the queen on B7
would be in danger so theoretically a
pin so a lot of us in chat are also
saying this move Rook to
C5 very very nice now Rook to C5 looks
like all of our pieces are on pre so
that means a lot of our pieces are
hanging that means white could probably
just take them well let's take a look at
White's options here white could maybe
take the queen on D7 they could take on
C5 with either the pawn or Rook let's
take a look at each one of them so if
the Rook on C7 captures Our Queen on D7
then we can deliver Checkmate in one as
we bring our Rook from C5 to C1 taking
away all the squares of the king and
attacking the
king all right and if the Rook takes
then we use our theoretical pin with
Queen D7 capturing the queen on B7 as
The Rook is no longer in the way of us
attacking and if white captures our Rook
with the pawn on D4 then what we can do
is bring our Queen on D7 bring it all
the way up towards the other side of the
board and deliver Checkmate on D1 as it
attacks the king and takes away F1 and
H1
one and if white does anything else
there's just too much pressure onto the
C7 Rook with two attackers and one
Defender so let's just say here and now
and then white tries to make some
breathing air for the king we can just
simply capture the rook and we'll be up
a lot of
material all right we are looking good
here all right how about we try this
position we have Layman versus Mueller
in
1952 and it is white to move here so
white has 1 2 3 four pawns black has 1
two 3 four five six pawns so black is up
two pawns both sides have a
queen both sides also have their Rooks
and both sides also have a dark Square
Bishop what we can notice here in this
position is that our King is very safe
as it's castled so we follow the opening
principles pretty well unlike for black
their King is still stuck in the center
and the center is where all the action
happens so danger is lurking for black
and we do have a pin in this position
Our Queen on A4 is pinning this queen on
D7 to the King on E8 so this queen
cannot to move to any squares like C7
otherwise wise the King on E8 would be
in danger and in addition to this pin AB
Queen on A4 is unprotected so if we are
careless let's say we make a pawn move
they're just going to capture Our Queen
on A4 completely for
free but how could we utilize this pin
and put pressure onto this queen on
D7
so how could we bring more attackers
onto the D7
Queen so if we notice here we have a
rook on D1 and this Rook on D1 is on the
same file as the queen on D7 so we can
take our Rook on D1 and simply capture
the pawn on D5 now it looks like it is a
bit of a mistake because our Queen on A4
is hanging but if the queen takes Our
Queen on A4 we can notice that the black
king on E8 has absolutely no squares to
go to so our Rook on D5 is covering D7
and d8 and our Bishop on A3 is covering
E7 and f8 so no squares at all so that's
that means all white needs to do now is
deliver the final blow and in which in
this position is to move Rook to E1 with
a check and now mate is inevitable all
black can do is really just delay the
checkmate with a couple blocks so Bishop
to E3 blocking Rook takes Queen blocks
and then bam we have check
mate and if White does anything if black
does anything
else to let's say hold on to this queen
let's say for example Rook to d8 we are
not going to capture the queen though
it's still a good move we win material
we can just continue the same idea of
playing Rook to E1 check and after the
bishop blocks then we can take with our
Rook delivering
Checkmate
excellent all right how about we give
this position a try so it is Evans
versus bis guire in
1958 and it is a white to move here so
white has one two three four pawns black
has one two three four pawns as well so
both sides are equivalent Pawn wise both
sides have a queen and both sides have a
rook and the light Square Bishop
respectively so in this position we
don't have a pin here so we're going to
need to create one and in addition here
black kind of has a pin on us so this
queen on E6 is attacking the bishop and
our Bishop can't move otherwise the
piece behind it The Rook on E1 will be
in danger so let's say if we play a
careless move like Bishop to F3 then we
then they can just capture our Rook with
check mate so that's a big blunder we
don't want to do that so how could we
maybe set up a pin in this situation you
can also notice that this king is really
misplaced it's on
f8 it the Rook is can't move at all
because the king is blocking its way and
there's this awkward Bishop on E8
here
okay so we do have a couple ideas of
maybe putting our Bishop on
C6 because if the queen let's say is not
there for visual visualization sakes
let's say queen of G6 we can capture
this bishop on E8 with our rook and it
will be supported by our Bishop here but
I want to kind of put that in our pocket
for the meantime I want to save that
move I want to build up this position
first okay and we also notice so good
brainstorming that ideas like Rook to E3
is just a tad bit too slow and maybe
black can kind of
react in preparation for any initiative
that white may
have so what we want to try to do is
kind of tickle the King on f8 a little
bit so what we're going to do is play to
move Queen to A3 with a check and with
Queen to A3 check black has two moves
here they can either block the check
with Queen to E7 or they can slide their
King to
G8 but if the King goes to G8 it's on a
light Square now and we have a light
Square Bishop so this is the perfect
opportunity for us to win some material
so what we can do is create a discovery
check SL attack in which Bishop takes H7
with a check so black has to react to it
so after black takes then our Rook on E1
will capture the queen and we have good
compensation a queen for a rook and a
bishop but now the big question is what
happens if the queen blocks and goes to
D7 now with the queen on E7 we can pull
out our idea that we have in our pocket
and now play to move Bishop to
C6 because this queen on D7 is pinned
because our Queen on A3 would be
attacking the King on f8 if the queen on
D7 was not
there so now with this in mind if black
just captures Our Queen on A3 then we
can take our Rook on E1 bring it all the
way to the other side of the board and
deliver Checkmate to the King on f8 as
abber Rook covers the E7 Square attacks
the King on f8 and guards G8 and it is
very well supported by our Bishop on
C6 and likewise if black tries to do
anything else there it the queen on D7
will fall so for example if Bishop takes
C6 we can take our Queen on A3 and just
captured the queen on uh E7 and then
made his right around the corner so King
G8 we can play Queen to E8 check Bishop
takes E8 and then we deliver the final
blow good Rook to E8
Checkmate very nice how about we give
this one so we're taking it up a notch
this one is a little bit more difficult
so we have pulson versus Hansen in
1990 and it is black to move here so
let's evaluate the position black has 1
two 3 four Five Pawns white has 1 two 3
four Five Pawns as well so both sides
are equivalent Pawn wise and both sides
also have two Rooks and respectively a
dark Square Bishop so in this case we
don't necessarily have a pin so it's our
job now to create a
pen and what we can notice here is that
one of the white King on F2 is on our
dark square and our Bishop specializes
on dark Square
so maybe we could try
to use that idea to try to win some
material Ed the fact that the king is on
a dark Square maybe we can line up one
of White's pieces onto a dark square and
then use our Bishop to win that
material so a very attractive move here
in this position would be the move Rook
takes
D4 capturing the bishop and we are
sacrificing here because the Rook is
worth more than the bishop but looks
like white could capture on
D4 and looks like we have a very nice
tactic of Bishop to B7 creating a pin so
if we really think about this if white
is Carol us we can just capture the rook
and we are up a minor piece but if this
happens well white won't do that because
they have the move King to E3 so they're
holding on to The Rook so if the bishop
captures here the king takes and if
anything here we just help the white uh
White centralize your king in the end
game which is not a good idea and if we
try to put pressure onto this Rook on D4
let's say with Rook to d8 we have two
attackers now on this rook and white has
one Defender white will just simply play
Rook to D2 and if the next move is given
white will step out the pin and be free
and if we try to just exchange
everything off it's just equivalent and
white is honestly just winning here now
as they'll take the B5 pawn and run
their pass Pawn down the
board so what we need to do is kind of
remove the defender so we notice that
this bishop is the defender of this Rook
uh the bishop is being defended by The
Rook on e4 so what we want to try to do
is kind of scare The Rook away and that
move would be Pawn to
F5 now with Pawn to F5 it is attacking
The Rook on e4 if the Rook let's say
goes to E3 then it loses the defense of
the bishop on D4 so then the Rook will
just capture and we have a pretty good
game here as black wins
material and if the white Rook let's say
goes to not G4 F4 or H4 we just simply
continue to attack The Rook with the
move Pawn to G5 and our pawns are just
dominating these squares so as The Rook
moves away then we can capture the
bishop with our Rook winning material
but now the main question comes to play
is what happens if white plays The Very
Special Move On
pant now as white on pant here then I
think we can deliver this idea of Rook
takes D4 and now as The Rook captures
back because white lost material they
should gain it back we can play Bishop
to B6 now pinning this Rook on uh D4 and
once white tries to hold on to this Rook
on D4 let's say with either The Rook
coming to D2 or the king going to E3 now
since we've kind of deflected this Pawn
away we can simply push our E5 pawn and
now after let's say white tries
to hold on to the Rook on D4 then we can
just simply capture the rook and after
the king moves away we successfully won
a whole Bishop in this position so we
want to try to build up to utilize our
pin sometimes all right let's do one
more of these and then we'll take a look
at a very special game that includes
pins so in this position we have
stalberg versus nidorf in
1947 and it is white to move here so
white has one two three four five six
pawns black has 1 two three four five
pawns so white is up a pawn both sides
have the Rooks both sides have a queen
and both sides have a bishop now in this
position we do not have a pin here so it
looks like we're going to have to create
a pin ourselves and now this position is
a little bit
tricky because of where all the pieces
are placed and we can't necessarily make
an effective move an effective pin right
off the bat but what we're going to you
need to do is kind of lure our opponent
in
here so a good thing to notice is that
we have a light Square bishop and it
specializes in the light squares so it
can only go on light squares we want to
maybe take advantage in this position of
maybe the light squares that kind of
surround the King on G7
here so could could we maybe try to
utilize this bishop
to set up a pin
here so we do have the idea of Bishop to
F7 now it looks like a bit of a crazy
move cuz we are
simply putting our Bishop on pre so it's
hanging and in addition since it's move
out the way the Rook On Da is now
attacking our Rook on D2 but if the Rook
captures on D2 We can just simply
capture on G6 because the bishop is now
there attacking the pawn on G6 as well
if the King goes to h8 then we have
Queen to G8
Checkmate and if the King goes to f8 I
think Queen takes F7 kind of seals to
deal here with the idea of just moving
the bishop out the way creating a
discovered attack and black can't really
do a move like Queen E7 to propose a
queen trade because there is this move
Queen to h8
checkm but now let's get on to the
critical moment instead of taking the
Rook can black just capture the bishop
on
F7 well if the king captures on on F7 we
have successfully set up a pin so our
Rook on F3 is attacking this bishop on
F6 and this bishop on F6 cannot move
away at all otherwise the king behind
the bishop would be in danger here
so what we can do now here is actually
capture The Rook on d8 Bishop can't take
once again because there's this pin and
if black captures with the queen on d8
then we have this nice tactic of playing
Queen to B7 with a check not only
attacking the king but also attacking
this Rook on A6 that is completely
unprotected so as the king moves away
from danger then we can take our Queen
on B7 and capture The Rook on A6 and we
are up the exchange we we have a rook
for their Bishop
here and if black tries to do anything
else let's say they try to unpin
themselves then we just get away with
taking a whole rook and we can move away
and we'll be up the exchange Rook for
Rook Queen for Queen and Rook for the
bishop perfect okay so I think we got a
good gist of creating pins and UTI ing
pins so how about we take a look at a
full game on how Frank Marshall was able
to defeat David Janowski using the ideas
of pins so we have David Janowski as
black here as white and Frank Jame Frank
James Marshalls as white as black so the
game opens up with Pawn to E4 Pawn to E5
Knight Knight to F3 Knight to F6 and we
have the Russian defense or the Petro
opening so white captures on E5 and
black pushes the pawn to D6 to scare
away the Knight on
E5 so the Knight simply returns back to
F3 and now black can safely capture the
pawn on e4 there's no ideas of Queen E2
trying to skewer the Knight to the king
because black simply just plays Queen E7
and the day is
saved so white just continues to
centralize by placing their Pawn on D4
and now this dark Square Bishop is able
to see so Pawn to D5 so black is just
fixing the position here now having more
visibility for this bishop to move
and Bishop to D3 is played by white so
simply developing they're one step
closer to castling and now just putting
a little bit of pressure onto this
Knight on e4 black just continues to
develop with Bishop to D6 so they're
doing the same thing they are developing
and getting ready to Castle the game
continued on with Pawn to C4 so White's
looking for ways to kind of chip away at
the center and and black now just
delivers the check with Bishop to B4 and
now instead of blocking the check let's
say Knight to D2 or Bishop to D2
Janowski decided to play King to F1 so
simply moving alongside with their King
losing castling privileges but getting
away from chck black simply castles here
the tension is released on D5 so C takes
Queen Queen takes and now Queen to C2 is
played so white has created a battery
here so the queen and Bishop are working
together to control the B1 and H7
diagonal and also kind of somewhat
creating a pin because if this Knight
moves away let's say D6 then this bishop
on uh D3 can capture the pawn on
H7 so hence why black just simply
supported the Knight on E 4 by playing
Rook to E8 and now white makes a bit of
a fatal mistake and plays to move Knight
to C3 and it looks very innocent because
White's just following opening
principles and developing but
unfortunately here black can just
capture this Knight and after white
captures back there is this very nice
idea of sacrificing the queen Queen on
F3 so Queen on D5 capturing the Knight
on F3 and the reason why this move is
very good is because after the pawn
takes on F3 then our Bishop on C8 will
slide all the way over to H3 attacking
the king forcing the king to go to G1
and then we can bring our Rook to E1 and
after white delays checkmate with Bishop
to F1 then Rook takes Bishop check
mate so why is white cannot capture the
queen on F3 so C takes B4 is played by
white
here and black is in no worry black is
not going to move their Queen because
the threat still renews and just
develops with Knight to
C6 now white continues by playing the
move Bishop to B2 simply developing and
now G takes F3 is now prevalent in this
position now black could always move
their Queen away let's say queen to H5
and defending H7 but black decides just
to capture on B4 and as the Knight
captures on B4 essentially what black is
trying trying to say is that if you take
my queen I will take your queen once you
capture back I will deliver a check on
H3 and as the King goes on H1 I'm going
to play this move Rook to E2 and deliver
a
skewer so hence why in this position
white just decides just to capture the
pawn on H7 a Pawn's a pawn and it's with
a check so black has to move away and
then and now white captures the queen on
F3 Bish Bishop to H3 check is played
first so an intermediate move an in
between
move and that forces the king to go to
G1 and then Knight takes C2 is played
Bishop takes C2 and then Rook to E2 we
have our skewer and it looks like black
uh excuse me white can defend the bishop
on C2 and stay up the material but what
black can do is finally bring all the
pieces into work by taking the Rook on
A8 and moving it to E8 creating a
battery so they these two Rooks are
dominating the open E file and if white
is careless let's say they push a pawn
there is this idea of Rook to E1 check
Rook takes and Rook takes
Checkmate so in the game Bishop to C3 is
played and now white uh excuse me black
now plays to move Rook 8 to E3 so there
is this idea of a pin because if this
Pawn takes our Rook on F3 then black has
this move Rook to G2 check after the
king moves to its only Square F1 we can
take our rook and capture G2 and it's a
check so if the King goes to G1 or E1
doesn't really matter both Rooks are
going to fall for white so King E1 Rook
takes C1 check King moves out the way
then Rook takes
H1 so that's why in the game white did
not capture but played the move Bishop
to B4 but now since this Rook is on E3
it can capture this Pawn on F3 which
does happen but it looks like both Rooks
are lined up on the light squares and
and white has this move Bishop to D1 to
skewer the Rooks so if one Rook moves
away the other one Falls but fortunately
here black just simply plays to move
Rook to F6 and Janowski throws in the
towel because if the bishop captures The
Rook on E2 then we have Rook to G6 check
if Bishop blocks on G4 Rook takes G4
checkmate and if white let's say holds
on a little bit or maybe tries to play a
move like Pawn to F4 there still renews
this threat of Rook takes
G6 so today we looked at pins on how we
can create them and utilize them to our
maximum Advantage so thank you all for
tuning in my name is National Master Ral
tan and that is beginner's
breakdown
[Music]
a